welcome back to precoc's coverage of the
2020 election black voters in georgia
turned out in record numbers for this
election and they'll be expected to do
it all
over again in january to determine which
senators they'll be sending to congress
tonight joe biden extended his lead
there to just over 4 000 votes the state
also single-handedly determined
the make will single-handedly determine
the makeup of the senate
as both of their senate races head to
runoffs in january republican incumbent
david perdue will attempt to fend off
democratic challenger
john ossoff after slipping under
georgia's required 50
benchmark and reverend rafael warnock
will battle republican incumbent kelly
lochler
after the two gained the most votes in
the state's
jungle primary and joining me now is
reverend warnock i'm so happy to chat
with you again
uh at the brink of this historic moment
um so first off
uh joe biden is maintaining his lead um
and
and should he continue to do so he would
be only the third
democrat uh president democratic
president to
win the state in 40 years in more than
40 years
and should you be victorious in your
race you'd be the state's
first elected democratic senator since
2000
how does that feel oh we're feeling
really good
uh this has been a
wonderful ride for me i'm a first time
candidate and we got in this race
january 30th in the special election
and we uh as we began to get our message
out to voters
they responded in a powerful way and and
i'm grateful that we are
we finished this part of the race in
such a strong position
i intend to keep carrying forth my
message
around access to affordable health care
the dignity of work and voting
you got the most votes in georgia's
jungle primary
um but obviously you know there were two
republicans in that
as well and so they split uh the
republican vote with the race narrowed
to
just the two of you do you feel
confident going into january's runoff
that uh
you will be able to succeed and come out
on top or do you expect it to be a
really challenging
uphill battle well there were more
democrats in the race than that there
were 21 people in my race
and because the names were listed
alphabetically and my last name begins
with the w
i was next to the last person on the
list um
but my message broke through and i'm
grateful for the momentum that we're
feeling
uh i am uh uh i i think that the
contrast between me
uh and uh kelly lesler who was appointed
not elected by the people of georgia
could not be stronger she has spent a
just a few short months
in the senate she's wasted no time
helping us to understand why she wanted
to be there in the first place
paid off really well for her she's
profited from the pandemic while
playing it down for voters
meanwhile people in georgia are still
waiting on relief
we haven't seen a covert 19 release
package obviously in months
the people that i'm talking to all
across the state are concerned about
their health care
they are facing unemployment possible
eviction
and they're wondering who can they send
to washington
uh that will look out for them i know
somebody i'd like to recommend
and i look forward to putting forth that
message of the campaign
in the last minute here you know we've
we've spent weeks talking about
the record voter turnout in georgia it
was really incredible to see
as early voting kicked off what's your
strategy for engaging voters
uh in the upcoming runoff obviously
you're gonna have to do
almost another sprint to the finish here
yeah we got less than 60 days and so
we're just going to work really hard
we're going to use
every avenue we can to reach voters
i've been moving all across this state
over the last few weeks and you know the
interesting thing to me
ser lima is that i go into small towns
places where they've lost their hospital
and they're surprised that someone
running for the senate
is in their town america's georgia
comfort georgia
i'm surprised that they're surprised i'm
running to be the senator for the whole
state
while to move around the state um but i
i uh intend to talk to ordinary people
and uh both you know through these the
ways in which we're moving physically
across the state but through all the
various media
and i think we're building momentum
that's gonna tip the senate our way and
and bring the kind of representation
that people of georgia need in the us
senate
rev raphael warnock thank you so much
again for joining us this evening